dans le ciel de kharkiv des volutes de
fumée et au sol ces pompiers qui luttent
pour éteindre les flammes des frappes
que sont touchés dimanche plusieurs
quartiers d'habitation du centre de la
ville hébétée ses habitants regardent
leurs immeubles par trop fume j'ai
appelé les pompiers ils ont dit nous
sommes en route les nous sommes aussi
bombardé j'ai demandé vous arrivez quand
ils ont répondu nous ne savons pas ils
sont arrivés très tard après environ 20
à 25 10 options et to dc a commencé à
brûler dans les rues jonchées de débris
les secours s'activent pour prendre en
charge les blessés
des opérations de sauvetage
interrompu par la menace des bois
cet homme lui a perdu sa fille dans les
bombardements
elle a été tuée je reçu un appel et on
m'a dit que ma fille avait été tué
dimanche soir le président ukrainien a
dénoncé cette attaque meurtrière pécho 0
j histoire jusqu'à présent cinq citoyens
de quartier vont été tuées et au moins
15 blessés dans ces frappes mais même
chez pire texte
qui s'intéressent au cours des quatre
derniers jours 18 personnes sont mortes
et 106 ont été blessées dans des frappes
russe sotchi ch les baye fall a pris
pour cible dès le début de la guerre
kharkiv deuxième ville du pays vit sous
le feu constant des bombardements depuis
que la russie concentre son offensive
sur l'est du pays le maire de kharkiv
appelle les habitants qui le peuvent à
fuir avec l'aide des autorités locales
nous continuons à évacuer les gens des
zones les plus dangereuses de la ville
qui sont sous des bombardements
incessants
le déplaçons les gens vers des endroits
moins dangereux parce qu'il n'y a plus
un endroit totalement sûr
plus de 500 civils ont été tués dans la
région de kharkiv depuis le début de
l'invasion russe